Joe Buck kind enough to call in the very
next day once again here on the Rich
Eisen show how are you Joseph they're
saying that call is going to go down in
history as one of the most recent yeah
why it's the latest you know it's
definitely the latest of all the
baseball calls that are out there right
now it's the latest well you know a Joe
um and and that's what makes it special
to me if I had a choice to take a selfie
with somebody last night named Joe
forget Torrey forget West it would been
buck it would have been buck you know
that well I know and we would have made
Smoltz take it in the booth well know
happy selfie would by the way that's not
that but wasn't it really wasn't it
selfie last night because they had a
they had Molina take the picture so it
doesn't really qualify as a selfie would
it been odd if I did just show up out of
the blue in the booth of the all-star
game last night and demand Yadier Molina
still take our picture of us in the
booth would that have been well no
because you should see what goes on in
our book we have it's like a petting zoo
there are people that come in there
people you know advertisers friends
family but there's not actual not
there's not actual livestock dojo right
I mean seriously
there's livestock in the booth there has
been like yes it was it was our tribute
to Joe Maddon
you know and I look I I loved the
interview with Bryce Harper during the
game that was fun that would never
happen during a regular season game
right Joe would that ever have now I
don't think no I don't think so
and that that's kind of the beauty of
where the game has gone now with fact
that this time it doesn't count I guess
but you can take more of an exhibition
type feel to it I think you could do it
in a spring training game but I don't
believe the Players Association for
baseball for that matter whatever okay
that but it was fun and it was cool and
both George Springer one half inning and
then Bryce Harper the other half innings
I thought they were terrific and Bryce
in particular I mean I what you don't
know is that he was supposed to go the
half inning before George Springer but
his microphone wasn't working so I'm
talking to him while he's in the
outfield trying to get him during the
commercial break that like jingle his
microphone transmitter around as if you
have any batteries on you put him in
there to do but he was nice enough to
leave the thing on and then he said I'll
just leave it on I don't care and I so
then he went back out there for the next
half inning and I said I'll just keep
you for a minute you've been more than
kind enough doing all this stuff and
said I'm bored out here I'll [ __ ] you
laughs enix oh I love that that's the
beauty of Bryce Harper who I think it's
a bad rip happen is actually a really
good guy and obviously crazy talented
yeah so let's let's let's get more into
that because it is if he is the face of
baseball and I think I think he is I did
get caught in the hole judge hysteria by
saying judge was the face of baseball
yesterday but that was just that might
have been the John sterling and me
coming out Joe with with with Harper's
medication is everything I think it's
like doctor first
probably but if if Harper is in fact the
face of baseball the fact that he gets a
bad rap or is not known to be as good as
he is how does that happen
Joe right well I think he I think he
came in you know the perception was
cocky and he was you know doing things
maybe before it was time for him to do
it as a rookie I think we all get caught
up in the unwritten rules that seem to
be more written than ever and I think he
rubbed people the wrong way but it's
just typical of you think you know
somebody from a distance and you get to
be around them I'm probably guilty of it
with Brice you may be guilty of it with
me I just think that's kind of a human
condition these days not to get
philosophical but you see somebody from
a distance you think you have him pegged
you think you know who they are and then
you meet him and go whoa I was way off
this guy's a great guy and and I'm
telling you I wouldn't even go into any
of this if he wasn't mmm he's a he's a
really good person
well when he said that he felt like a
commentator for a network I loved his
choice of network that he mentioned
during the interview last night well
yeah was what was an NFL Network yeah
that would be at Joe
yeah that's the one yeah yeah I have
that on my on my cable so it's not
obliged data like this show is so is he
a Cowboy fan because of all the players
for him to pull out you mentioned dak
Prescott he's from VII don't know I
guess so I I wasn't aware of that and
then when he when he brought up dak come
out of the blue it took me a man I don't
know a lot of a lot of people certainly
I don't know a lot of people named dak
so you would think that would
immediately trigger a response from me
but the response in my head was wait a
minute dak who's dead oh oh dak dak
Prescott and and then we were going into
a football conversation but for a second
there that tested every ounce of my
intelligence well hey look I mean you're
locked into an all-star game I mean and
the last thing you're giving a
figurative curveball to come your way
would be to be asked a football question
by the right fielder that you're you're
interviewing in the middle of the actual
game they're you know yes that's their
so and when it all comes down to it
though do you think this game needs
fixing does this game need to be tweaked
in the same way that they tweaked the
homerun Derby with that with that with
that shot clock that was terrific so
what do you think about the all-star
game uh I mean it just depends I think
they could send some trial balloons in
the all-star game like we did with the
coverage talking to guys be on deck
circle a-rod walking out there talking
outfielders during the game talking to
managers live not taping between innings
you know I think you can do some of that
stuff if you wanted to maybe tweak how
they would do extra innings if you got
there and do the runners on deal one out
and see if you can get the guy over
whatever they want to try or try this
try to pitch clock you know I think
there's now opportunity now that you
know the home-field advantage in the
World Series doesn't ride on the winning
league that said I kind of feel like
there was something missing after 14
years you know this time it counts and
and I felt like it was a little flat
without that but again it allowed us to
do stuff we wouldn't typically do so
there's give-and-take and everything and
maybe that's cooler to the fan
and has more opportunity to try stuff if
you're Major League Baseball with regard
to speeding up the game in an exhibition
type setting instead of something that
determines who starts the World Series
what do you think a harper suggestion
that the top vote-getters in each league
take the entire pool of players that
have been voted in and choose sides and
just do away with American versus
National what do you think of that
because that way I know you can that
doesn't hit me right no no but I know
that that that completely takes down the
concept of what the all-star game has
always been but you could bring up you
could get Kershaw versus Posey you could
get you could get Kim Burrell versus
judge and I know we're seeing that even
this weekend but when it comes down to
an all-star game moment six seventh
eight innings
maybe that's the sort of Joel Pett that
the game might need why I would rather
go the complete opposite way and have
the best players from each league maybe
that means the team doesn't get
represented and these guys play pretty
much a full game and if you don't get in
then be better next year and get in the
game if you do you're playing the
ballgame like a normal ball game and
maybe you need another day off on either
side of the all-star break to allow the
best pitcher to be ready to pitch in
that game but I would rather see it go
the other way I don't know about
choosing sides and I it just feels NHL
NBA to me I think the the Major League
Baseball all-star game is still by far
the best of the four major sports
all-star games and I wouldn't go that
far I don't think it needs that well
it's the one that closely resembles it
actually resembles an actual regular
season if not postseason game based on
any of the all-star games it's the only
one yeah I'm okay and and I think that's
that's good you know I think that's a
good thing
that differentiates it from the the
other leagues are trying to drum up
interest I don't see building away with
American versus National and scrapping
something that's been going on since
1933 I you know I'm the last person that
would consider myself a you know an
obstructionist or some sort of
traditionalist in baseball but I
I don't like that idea are you turning
it to Costas on me during this
conversation thing is I think bad that
just happened my god [ __ ] I I don't know
all of a sudden I feel you came in Joe
Buck in you're leaving Bob Costas oh
really
Wow that transfusion right before our
very eyes
yes very frightening you're on the
recharging show undeniable with Joe Buck
returns for season three on the 18th of
October a rod is your first guest is
that as they say already in the can did
you know that interview already - oh
yeah that we've got a whole season done
okay which includes Bobby Knight Jeff
Gordon David Robinson the Admiral and
right on down the line so yeah a rod was
great you know sometimes a rod comes off
as really rehearsed and he was at times
because I think he's really protective
about what he says certainly with regard
to his PDUs and the history of all that
but man he was great and and I've really
gotten to like him a lot and then
another guy who I think you see from a
distance you have some opinion as to
what kind of a person they are and then
you get to know him and you realize you
were completely wrong and and so I've
really enjoyed my time around I mean
he's a wonderful guy was JLo off to the
Sun on the set with the Jesus that crap
with that was JLo off to the side offset
no no III did I think I made the joke
that on our Fox pregame we've got you
know a guy that's dating JLo and his
name's not Pete Rose because Pete was
uninterested would not return our calls
[Laughter]
okay and so um with with the whole
situation Joe for for you and undeniable
and what you do with them and
occasionally pull on the heartstrings
who'd you get to cry who cried this
season um Alex cried a little bit all we
want to stay with Alex Bobby Knight
maybe a little what but yeah he was
emotional he was now I don't know what
makes the final cut so when it gets on
air I'm looking at it for the first time
myself Joe I didn't realize that Alex's
episode was the first one up and I did I
just
worthy of that did I just break
undeniable news to you you did huh and
and by the way I'm calling it undeniable
with Joe Buck / Bob Costas from here yes
you for season four by the way so um so
those things in the corners of Bob
Knight's eyes can emit some form of
salty liquid is that what you're saying
yes no I'm here to tell you he's got a
heart he was great I mean man he was he
went for three hours
well it was it to Indiana guys talking
those are two Indiana guys talking right
there exactly I talked to his son Pat
and he had just gotten a pacemaker not
long before that and it really kind of
perked him up to the point where I you
know he wouldn't stop talking it was it
was fantastic so that one is really
interesting because he has some very
strong opinions about John Wood and he
certainly doesn't hold back which he did
not disappoint
in that area well look if somehow
someway Bob night getting emotional and
crying does not make the final edit of
season four of undeniable
I will storm the Edit Bay with a
pitchfork and a torch on your behalf Joe
that's going to make an issue and then
we'll we'll break the footage on on your
show okay
Joe you're the best thing don't be
scared to to put my book lucky bastard
up next to the Bryan Cranston book by
the way um do we have an autographed
copy of lucky bastard broken hallelujah
I don't think I've got thirty of them
under my bed right now right now it's a
four for your edification
it is a Joey Logano signed Pennzoil
container a Bryan Cranston autographed
book a Gronk autographed book and the
latest cover of Nantucket Magazine of
Bill Belichick and his boo as they might
say answer tomorrow yeah fantastic
currently the wait well I'm going to
think about that while I go through
security here at Miami International
Airport and feel like Leonardo DiCaprio
- McMahon you know you take care of safe
place well I just walked through the
terminal with 15 flight attendants my
gosh Wow catch him if you can everybody
have a great flight take care jock okay
so you got you got a choker the Rich
Eisen show weekdays at noon eastern on
radio stations across the country and
audience if you like that video be sure
to download our apps don't have any
memory on your phone let's start to
delete some of those slo-mo videos you
have and you know which ones I'm talking
about